welcome to the market motive workshop on
paid search with our faculty chair brad
geddes brad is the author of advanced
adwords and the advanced google adwords
to be specific the founder of certified
knowledge and the PPC faculty chair here
at market motive today Brad is going to
be telling us how to hone your AdWords
data with pivot tables some of us may
say own but with that there's a couple
of logistics for those of you who are
joining us Brad usually teaches us
directly for I don't know between ten
fifteen twenty or thirty minutes to
paying how long he's generous for and
then we switch over to Question and
Answer where if you have a question
well mute you let us know if you don't
have a microphone but in the meantime we
want you to be able to post your
questions ahead of time so because we
have some new folks joining us today I
want you just to give a try right now
open up the questions and answers or the
questions window over to the right on
your screen and type in an encouraging
message or something that you're looking
forward to learning today that way we
know you're attentive we know you're
there we know you can ask questions and
it helps encourage us along go ahead
right now find that question answer
window type in something encouraging
something that you want to learn
something that you want to know so we
know you're listening it here we go
we got Davis pivot tables and caps ways
to compare multiple data sources in one
report Diego says okay dance is looking
forward to learning how to explore tune
the tables where he's glad to be here we
see a lot more coming in so we have a
live and excited audience and this is
great so Brad over to you pivot tables
for the search marketer all right so
often when we're getting into data
there's there's too much information
that any account can generate then we
can effectively analyze and and so a
pivot tables do is lets you aggregate
that data at a higher level and then
pivot it which is what they're called
pivot tables so what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to just flip over to excel for a
second and and walk through the basics
of making a pivot table and then we're
gonna go back to PowerPoint in look at a
lot of examples of
good pivot tables to use to analyze your
data so what I'm gonna build here is
just a simple one for Quality Score so
let's say that I just took over an
account and I'm trying to figure out
from a high level does the account have
a good call to this Court does it have a
bad quality score because if there if
it's bad then I probably need to work an
organization and add testing if it's a
really good quality score a polity to
focus more on bidding so just a high
level I want to know a simple question
such as is he account holistically
something Google's gonna like or not and
this is a really simple thing that to
figure out with the pivot table so what
I have here is and you don't have to
miss a small data it's fine all I'll
make it bigger the next screen but what
what I'm to make a pivot tables on I
have a basic export from Google this is
just the keyword report that includes
click that impression costs and quality
score and what I want to do is select
all my data so go to the corner you can
select everything go to insert pivot
table and and then it's gonna ask you to
verify this is the data source I could
change it if I wanted to this is fine
and so now what I have it is just blank
data to start with and so I need to pick
what I want to look at and so often you
want to start with your row your your
key piece of data so in this case we
care about quality score so I want to
put my quarter score up first now when
I've got these rows here I can filter
the data very simply so what I don't
want to see are like blanks and totals
that may screw up my dad up so I can
click on the filter just like an Arras
in Excel and remove those now what I
want to know then is from an impression
basis what how how many impressions do I
have and each score level and what's
their percentage so when you add
something it makes it to the rows but I
can just drag this down to values so now
I have my quality scores my row data and
my count of impressions which would be
how many times is appear what I want to
see is sum of impressions pivot tables
do count by default
so there's two ways I can change how
this data is calculated I can either
click over into the pivot table field
and choose value field settings or just
simply double click into the top row
change this to some and now this is
gonna show me how many impressions I
have by these quarter score ranges so
what I really want to know now is what's
the percentage of each of these rows so
when we get into calculations or there's
two ways to do calculations to answer
this question I could simply write a for
me right in the pivot table so
percentage of Q s or percentage of
impressions by Q s and that can write a
simple formula equal sum of B 4 divided
by B 13 now I made this mistake on
purpose all I'll walk through in a
second what you don't want to do in
pivot tables when you're writing your
values is click into the field because
all of a sudden you got this crazy get
the table data and it can make your form
is very complex also a just a quick hint
on excel if I were to write this formula
B 4 divided by P 13 so how many
impressions does cause for one word have
divided my grand totals and I hit enter
obviously it's 0% but normally when you
have an excel formula you can just
double click and it drags it all down
now the problem here is excels pretty
smart and what happened is it dragged it
down it said we probably want to know B
5 by B 14 the next row and then for the
next one B 6 by B 15 so when you write
formulas and this goes past pivot tables
dollar signs are absolutes they say as
you drag a formula don't change this
part of the equation so if I added
dollar sign B and dragged it down it
would never change the fact its column B
but it would change the row from 13 14
and 15 but if I do dollar sign B dollar
sign 13 it's saying absolutely as I
change this only change the divisor here
B 14
by this absolute number so now I can
drag this down and I can see my
percentage of quality score for each of
my percentage of impressive these
quality score now if you again select
the row go to go to your formats we want
to split this to a percentage now a
healthy account is one that Google likes
and if we've got most of our keywords at
7 or higher then we probably have good
quality scores now if you highlight
stuff in Excel you can look down the
bottom here now this is hard to read but
it's eighty nine point seven percent of
my impressions are seven or higher this
accounts an in pretty good shape now
often when we were looking at things the
problem with me writing a formula
directly in the pivot table is let's say
I wanted to see my click-through rate by
Quality Score just to see cuz normal
week as Klaus froze up so his
click-through rate so if I wanted to add
more data such as how many clicks I have
per each particular Quality Score I'm
gonna have to overwrite my formulas to
get that data and so that's the problem
of writing form was quick and easy to do
but there's another way of doing it
so let me just add my clicks and my
impression dad will make the Summa
clicks and so let's say I want to know
my click-through rate by Quality Score
another way of doing this then so that
it becomes part of the pivot table so
you can move it around not overwrite
your data is going to fields calculated
field now I can't name this just CTR
because I already have a row called
click-through rate so I need to make
this all this is qsr CTR now this is
just like writing a regular forma I
would want to know what is my click data
equals sum of click data / impressions
and enter that and now I have another
field then that is now in the pivot
table that shows me
my click the rate by quality score and
this is really common as click the rate
goes up so does quality score it's a
fairly common thing to see we've got a
little exception here now though this is
a great overview but what it's not
letting me see is if I have something
like a good brand that might be hiding
bad collar school because maybe my brain
is really prevalent so often you want to
filter your data by brand and non brand
or brand and longtail so forth so pivot
tables also have a filtering section so
I can drag my campaign into filters this
adds my campaign dad up here and then I
could just deselect and say show me just
the brand data and so here's my quality
score data for the brand in this case
our most of our impressions are at nine
and ten perfect I could then redo this
and say show me the data for my non
brand information and so this is an easy
way then if we've got our impressions by
quality scores come right the singles
it's really fast or weighted if you're
not gonna overwrite your data later on
um
efore / ping to see if you know my brand
is strong and has high quality scores if
my brand is low has low quality scores
so just by simply filtering back and
forth I could get an overall impression
and so that's the basics of pivot tables
you got what data do you want to see
what data do you want to see it by and
and then how do you want to look at it
and so we're gonna do it is now jump
into PowerPoint and talk about one of
the nuances of calculated fields and
then look at other ways to use things so
with pivot tables a big big no-no is to
do an average of a derived metric so for
instance
pay the tables just do aggregate based
information they don't do weighted
information by default so let's say that
I wanted to see my click-through rate by
ad group now a groups if I've got a
keyword based out of here I don't
actually have an aggregate through it I
have all my keywords in an ad group
click-through rate so if let's say I've
got one a group that's got one click in
one impression that's a hundred percent
click-through rate let's say I've got a
second a group I've got 100 clicks on a
thousand impressions that's a ten
percent click-through rate now my
average click-through rate if I just did
an average and a pivot table it would
say it's 55 percent oh that looks great
that's a really misleading number I
would really want to see what's my
weighted average information which in
this case is a ten point zero zero one
percent click-through rate so that's
what calculated fields are really useful
because you can put the raw data and
clicks impressions then calculate the
click the rate in the pivot table with a
calculated field as opposed to doing the
average of a derived metric like
click-through rate conversion rate any
of your drive metrics because that is
gonna give you some really misleading
information and so again that's where
calculated fields are great and this
would be the difference so if I did
average of click the right here is if I
just wanted the pivot table and said
show me my averages my sum of CTR by
call to score is my calculated field
weighted information and so it can be
useful sometimes to look at this because
that called a score for I have a massive
difference between the two here so my
weighted CTR is a 5.97 my average is a
0.26 percent now what this tells me
because I've done this way too many
times is that I probably have 10 or 20
ad groups that overall sit in the for
cause go range and the vast majority of
them have little click-through rates but
I probably have one
word that has most of the impressions
that has a great click-through rate but
it's a cause for forward so odds are
it's a landing page issue for that
particular word because the
click-through rates too high and the
rest of the words would fall into their
bad CTRs or bad relevancy and so it can
be useful to kind of look at some of
these but we'd never want to look at
averages of averages that that's gonna
lead you down a path of really bad data
so just make sure you're doing that
weighted information and so that's just
a quick way of just the Inc laws for
health now we talked about these so
let's continue on so let's say then I
look at the account and I see wow we do
have some quality score problems so what
I want to know next then would be where
should I start digging into the account
so that I'm using my time wisely to
improve quality scores so then what I
could do is change my row labels to be
my actual ad groups and then I could
look at cost and say how much has is AG
respect until then what I really want to
know is what ad groups are spending a
lot of money that have bad quality
scores now this again is where weighted
averages are really important so if I
just did hey pivot table give me my
average quality score at this this one
ad group here guessed Howells my average
is a six point one four now my weighted
average is a four point seven because I
went to the ad group level here I don't
want look every single keyword I want to
find big areas and then drill down to
the a group to fix it and so to create
weighted data here we actually have to
change our source just a touch so if we
go back to our source data this would be
the report we downloaded from Adwords
and we just make another simple column
which is quality score times impressions
for every keyword let's make a simple
column now if you add additional
information to your source data when you
go back to your pivot table you
to refresh your data or change the
source so we'd go back and we'd say add
this additional information in here then
again we want to use a calculated field
so we can sort and filter by this and
since we're dealing with a drip data
which is the sum of keyword information
just by adding a simple formula show me
my callers call times impression data
divided by impressions now will give me
weighted quality score by adverb so now
I can look at where I've got low cause
Coors high cost and look at information
now in pivot tables you can do some
basic sorting like let me sort by it my
cost high to low or let me sort my call
to score my lowest to my highest but
when you want to get into a lot of
filtering pivot tables aren't great for
it this is where your standard sorting
and filtering and a regular sheet can be
useful so you can select your pivot
table data just click on the top corner
like we showed earlier hit ctrl C go to
your your new sheet
paste it in and by default Excel is
gonna make a pivot table but you'll see
a little icon where you can paste
special so you want to do is paste this
information just as values so now we'll
have the numbers and a new sheet without
the pivot table behind it powering it
that we can sort and filter at will so
if we think of anak laws garena we've
got one aspect which is I've spending
money in places that I could probably
increase quality scores and reduce my
spend or increase my add ranks and so
back to simple way and our filters we
could say show me keywords that my
quality score is below 4 and my cost is
above $100 for the ad group now filter
clause for high to low or low to high
either way or show me places where my
quality scores below for my cost is over
$1000 and let's work by cost so you
could either way is fine I'm but this is
going to find areas then to improve
quality a step on way
you're spending money now but we have
times where we just wants a more traffic
so you could do that same that same
filter and just do impressions high to
low these are places where you're you're
getting a lot of impressions but you're
probably not getting a lot of clicks cuz
you have some sort of bad relevancy so
that be a place to increase traffic from
where you've got existing impressions
now the other issue of claw score is
though if it's too low then you just
don't get shown at all or you're shown
very irregularly and so another way then
we can go back to our pivot table we can
then add a quality score is a filter and
say just show me words that have you
know one two three quality scores show
me how many keywords by a group have
clawed scores one two three these are
probably a groups then that are probably
not well organized and then sort most
keywords to least so give me these
bottom one here logo cops whoops logo
cups has 96 keywords out of one two
three ninety six is a lot for an ad
group ninety six that have low quarter's
forces a lot that a group probably needs
some organizational help so beyond
Quality Score there's a lot of other
ways we can use pivot tables so the next
stuff we're gonna walk through is
looking at the query data so if you go
into your account go to keywords go to
search terms you can see the actual
search terms someone used to trigger
your ads so one of our big questions is
have we lost ad serving control in other
words for the same keyword query do we
have multiple ad groups that are showing
because if you've got more than one a
group showing for a keyword then we
probably have some problems where
Google's selecting our ads and landing
pages not us and markers should be a bit
of control freak so this is a simple
pivot table where the search term is a
row number of ad groups is our values
and then we can simply see
is the number greater than one if it's
greater than one this queries been shown
from more than one agar if we might have
a problem then we could add things like
cost data cuz if you spent ten cents you
may not care it's been shown from three
AG groups or or impression data how
common does this occur but sometimes
having just what more than one ad group
showing for query isn't a bad thing
sometimes it's okay so let's say you're
in lead generation and you're in car
insurance lead gen and you have one
campaign for Chicago one campaign for
Los Angeles one campaign for New York
well these are different campaigns so a
query being shown from multiple
campaigns that don't compete because
they're different geographies that's not
our problem what you really care about
is do the words compete so if you've got
segments where it's logical but you have
more than one Agra bet shown because
they're different geographies then what
you really care about is within a
campaign has more than one Agravaine for
this so in this case what I've done is
my initial row was my search query I
added to the pivot table a second row
which is the campaign so now my pivot
table is segmented query then campaign
information and now I can see how many
ad groups have shown for a query within
each campaign so that's another way of
looking at it
nothing is I don't want to look at all
this data because it's so much to
examine I want a nice visual key to
trigger in my eyes on this is where
conditional formatting Excel is great so
conditional formatting there's a lot of
lot of uses to it a simple one is just a
simple rule that says highlight cell
cell rules greater than or less than a
specific number and so we're gonna use
this for this in a moment here but just
give you an idea of uses of this let's
say you're writing ads in Excel but
you're gonna you know white a mid bunch
a right mo formulas and then paste them
in the AdWords editor to put your
account and your writing in a thousand
ads at once well a nice simple rule
would be if my headline is greater than
25 characters because Google rejected
highlight it read right if my headline
is under 10 characters highlighted
orange because we're not taking a bunch
of character counts so that's a lot of
ways to use conditional formatting but
in this case we're just gonna say if
within a campaign this ad group has been
shown this query has been shown from
more than one ad group highlight it red
and then take my cost out of next to it
and now what I'm looking for is anything
that's in red because it's lost ad
serving control I can sort cost high to
low and that can start with the places
I'm spending the most money where I've
lost ad serving control so that's
another simple way of using pivot tables
in and and our last workshop we did an
hour on this or something so just from a
simple standpoint that's work ad group
level negative keywords are great to
help control that information campaign
level negative keywords just don't show
me a group level is really more about
ensuring Google shows the correct ad for
any query because if we had a query as
such in this case like sheep VPS website
hosting and we didn't have negatives
every single a group could show for a
cheap VPS web site query so this force
is due Google to show the correct ad
correct landing page for us now another
good question pivot pivot tables can
answer in your campaign options by
default now Google shows exact and frees
match words shows them too for
misspellings plurals or really close
variants so the question is is this a
good or bad setting and it's not it's
good for some people it's bad for others
it's not a global turn off turn on it's
more about your account so if you take
that query data again what you first
want
if you're using modified broad match by
default and a keyword Data Report Google
combines brought a modified brought
together so go to your keyword report
that you initially downloaded do a
filter and then full the actual keyword
just do a simple filter that says if
keyword contains a plus sign which means
it's modified broad match then show me
those words and your match type change
it to broad - modified so that now your
match types are broad broad modified
phrase phrase variant exact exact
variant etc so now we can take this
information put into pivot table and we
can look to see how do our individual
match types perform for us and so in
this particular case for exact and exact
close variants our exact close variant
is actually it touched better than our
exact matches which means we probably
have some words we want to add to our
account
now our close variant phrase is way
worse than phrase match which means you
probably have some words we want to add
as negatives to the account so in this
case this is this is a very mixed signal
because it's good for exact it's bad for
phrase however it's added a lot of
conversions exact match close variance
compared to phrase so overall the the
overall impact is probably positive
leave it on just need to add some more
queries and negative keywords but this
is a easy way of just seeing how your
match types are performing now in this
particular case the cost clicks and
conversion data because it's straight
metrics is just done from a source the
cost per action and conversion rate we
would not want to do in the pivot table
from a peer use my average of conversion
rates because again that's doing derive
metrics averages of drive metrics so
those are just calculated fields at a
CPA conversion rate calculated field and
now you can see that the true convert
rates for your broad modified excetera
match types if we get into say ad
testing with with our testing now
especially you know one enhance holdout
by a year ago now we have device
preferred ads and so if and this is if
if your campaign is showing on desktop
and mobile devices then you want to
control the user experience what ads are
seeing on landing page they they go to
by device type and so what we really
want to know are are things like art do
we are we testing ads by device do we
have ad serving issues by device and one
of the worst cases that happens is if
you have an ad group that only has
mobile preferred ads in it so you you
were thinking about mobile users maybe
even a mobile destination URL and that
at a group does not have a desktop at
your mobile ads or sewing on desktops if
you're sending to a mobile specific site
your desktop users are going to mobile
sites so we want to be able to see real
quickly is by ad group how do our ad
stack up so if you go into your columns
information and AdWords ad device
preference to your ad data we can make
another quick pivot table where we've
got our ad line we want to see our row
labels or our group information and then
we have mobile and all in our our value
information and then we just want to say
how many ads exist in each of these
conditions mobile or all by ad group and
then add conditional formatting where if
ad is only one then make it yellow
because we're controlling serving there
but we're not testing if we have no ads
in the aggregates blank make it red
because we're not controlling the user
experience there so for instance in a
Group one here we have two mobile
preferred we have know all device ads
our mobile ads are showing on desktops
a group - oh there's no ads at all okay
so this ad group is getting zero
impressions and the reason why is we
forgot to add ads you're a group three
we have a mobile ad good we're testing
desktops we're not testing mobile yet so
that's a good case so go ahead and test
mobile and so just by using a pivot
table and a touch of conditional
formatting you can look to see where you
need to create ads so that you're
testing and controlling user experiences
appropriately by device also another
good usage of pivot tables is when
you're testing ads across multiple ad
groups at once so string based testing
or pattern based testing so for instance
if you've got accounts that have so many
a groups in it you can never ever write
all the ads you're gonna write formulas
now if you've got a really small account
and you're not spending a lot of a lot
of money per ad group will you also can
use this technique to aggregate data at
an add line level so you can make
statistically significant decisions even
though you don't have that much data for
and in so by being consistent in your ad
writing initially then we can take our
data by add line levels this is for
description light - and then see across
all these ad groups how does any one
line perform so in this particular case
the description line - a free shipping
option is our best conversion for
impression in fact it does way better
than free shipping options shop now for
this particular account a lot of
accounts will see that having some
particular call to action and will do
better but this is why we test and so
this is a easy way then of doing testing
when you have big big accounts and have
to use formulas or if you've got little
amounts of data I need to a good at some
way I her get it by headline or
description one description - as long as
you're consistent in your ad writing now
we can also be useful here is labels
because if yours
I'll go back to karlie generation for
whatever reason so let's say you you're
selling car insurance but you're
wondering what works better car
insurance in geography name and
geography name could switch dependent
course where you're showing your ads
versus cheap car insurance so but the
problem with that is a PivotTable by
default would give you one line for
cheap car insurance you would give you
another line for cheap car insurance in
LA cheap car insurance in Chicago and
and you don't really care so Sara Lee
about each geography you want to know
what's more important putting the
geography the ad or emphasizing a price
point so if you use labels instead you
can define what labels you want you
could make it geography versus non
geography you could do it hey these are
the different conversion types we have
and then you can use a label either as a
filter or to even pivot the data data on
to see which is doing better and so you
know for enterprise accounts we could
list out all right these ads or go with
newsletter conversions or these ads are
brand based ads and so then you know we
apply our labels to our ads and then our
pivot table we just do a segment say
some of the ads whose goal is to get a
newsletter subscription somebody adds
his goals through this a label filter
then look at which ad line is doing
facets don't want to keep now of course
what happens in reality is when you sort
your your metric whatever you want to
take your data by you're gonna have some
ad groups that's great for the sidelines
but you're gonna have some that aren't
quite as good so if you leave your
totals and just sort then you can see
the ad groups that are below the average
and so the ad groups that are that are
below that sort of benchmark average if
they're high impression words or high
impression ad groups you probably want
to pull them out of a pattern based
testing and test them individually now
if it's just for all longtail and you're
not gonna manage these 300 a groups
individually because a long tail yours
gonna keep doing pattern based testing
that's fine it's acceptable loss when
your enterprise dealing the flawed of
longtail items now sometimes we'll be
given the data and there's just too much
to look at where you think and say well
I need to see this data just on Sundays
or I want to quickly see I built this
whole pivot table to see click the rates
and and conversion per impression data
but I want to quickly be able to see it
by brand or non brand or this I want to
see by individual tau hour of day so if
you go to your pivot table and you
insert a slicer you can pick the data
you want to slice on you'll see these 1
2 3 columns but how many you make and
you can simply build some basic data and
then just say show me this by Sunday so
missed by Wednesday show me this by
campaign a campaign B so you don't have
to build you know what hundred and
forty-eight pivot tables whatever it be
to see your conversion rates by hour day
by day of the week you can very simply
use slicers and just slice the data
that's being displayed based upon these
quick conditions which can be any column
you have in your source data now
something that's kind of nice is just to
get an overview of your account you
might want to know things like how many
key words to be had by a group or do we
have site links and all our campaigns
and say if you've got a hundred
campaigns trying to check if you have
site links in every campaign is a pain
so much easier way of doing this go to
the AdWords editor you download your
copy editor export your account put it
in a pivot table and then you can easily
see things like here's how many keywords
we have by campaign by ad group and we
could sort highest lowest and say wow we
have a whole lot of keywords in these ad
groups here we need better um better
organization or how many ads do we have
by ad group or how many site ones do we
have by either campaign or a group in
this case I did campaign in segment two
a group level cycling's some cases you
don't you could just leave it your row
labels campaigns your value is just
slightly do you have at least four site
links and each those campaigns this
would take about thirty seconds to see
if you're missing a camp site links in a
campaign doing that the interface can
take you ten minutes and so even just
from a big overview standpoint using the
adwords editor downloading your account
and flow into PivotTable can give you
quick information about how robust an
account is quick weak spots in an
account and pivot and then find those
areas to go really work in and so i mean
when you think of pivot tables really
they're great for analyzing large data
sets and they're really easy to make I
made that first one I could make it in
about eight seconds you know the first
couple you make me take it a little bit
after you've made three four or five of
these they're fast and so just some
things to remember never do averages of
averages or averages of calculated data
if it's a derived metric click the rate
conversion rate cost per action never
use that information a pivot table use
calculated fields or write a formula
into the pivot table but don't do
averages of derived data if you need to
do a lot of sorting a lot of filtering
it is quicker I mean you can do it pivot
tables but it's just faster you know
copy it into a new sheet paste those
values only and then you can filter and
sort like you would your regular type of
data and then conditional formatting it
makes Excel way more vision was a lot of
formatting you can really use for
conditions and you can also sort so you
can take the data you'd like say the at
copy sheet we have and then you could
paste that when you've got your a group
number of mobile ads number of desktop
ads into a new sheet and then sort by
red hey here's not we're not um
controlling ads through my device or
sort by yellow here's what we need to do
or I'd test it you can sort by colors in
Excel and if you've got too much data
there's just too many things to look at
try using the slicer we
can just look at specific sets campaigns
day of the week whatnot on any point in
time it and quickly refresh the data so
that you're almost using a different
data source you know segmented by
campaign segmented by you know noon
whatever
I'm very quickly of course you want to
learn more about AdWords then we're here
at Markham owner to help you out of what
all right Michael I'm gonna turn it back
to you for a second take a sip of coffee
absolutely well-deserved thanks Brad
okay so we got a number of questions now
is your time to go ahead and either
raise your hand inside of the systems
let raise your hand function or else you
can just type in your question and we'll
unmute you I've got Galia lined up David
and Gary will be coming to you in just a
moment by the way if you are a master
cert student or candidate let us know we
tend to give you a little bit of
preference and put you on the spot
sometimes too but only in a good way and
if you haven't joined the master circuit
class we certainly encourage you to
register for that that's a coached
course we're Brad and one of the
instructors here at market Gordon
Philippa actually highly qualified the
author walk you through Brad's course
all right Brad hopefully you've got a
little bit of caffeine in you and Gary
is already PPC master certified I know
you are Gary big fan and I'm trying to
remember your company name Gary and
where some of your sites are alright
let's say I grab
Galia and going I'm gonna try to mute
you if I remember right you're from a
little further away than some of our
folks here but we'll see if you've got a
good connection going do you I have a
question for breath yes I just have a
quick question Brad so I know this
course is mainly for Excel just people
to know our people tables in Excel but
my question is why do you do here and
I've it wasn't clear what needs to be
done to fix the problem of same search
term appearing in different ad groups
for the same campaign so you met you
mentioned that your third gain search
term for different ad groups but if
they're different campaigns that's okay
because they're covering different
geographic area okay so which game
campaign what do you do
okay so if the query doesn't compete
different campaigns in areas not a
problem if it does then what you need to
do is look at your ad group structure
and then and then add negatives
appropriately so let's pretend that that
query here is cheap VPS website hosting
in each one of these is an ad group so
of a hosting a group with the hosting
keyword website hosting cheap host and
so forth
so for a query like cheap VPS website
hosting I got asked the question which a
group is most appropriate right that's
something you can't automate which is
most appropriate so the user use cheap
so their discount shopper and VPS
Virtual Private servers way more
important than a regular hosting and in
so then what I can do is I can layer in
my negative so hosting is - cheap and -
VPS and my website hosting - cheap - VPS
and build up my negatives by ad group to
force the most specific query to be
displayed does that make sense
golly we have muted herself I hope she
got the answer golly let us know yep we
got you know absolutely thanks for
joining us David
you have a question for Brett good I
wish is curious about the string based
testing you were talking about I haven't
heard of that you said string base and I
believe it was formula based testing
what exactly is that so so let's say
that I've got a account that is so big I
can never write all the ads or maybe
I've got a really tiny business account
right and I can't get enough data by add
to reach statistical significance so
what I what I can do then is start at a
high level and say what do I want to
know do I want to know does geography
matter more than headline than a
callback for my description line - what
matters more
saying free shipping or um something
that is more hey shop now or college for
a free quote right you've got a few
different ideas and so if I take that
and I say here's my free description
line twos I can wipe my ads as normal in
in each ad group but then for my
description line - I'm gonna make sure I
use these three sets right across every
single ad group and so then now I'm
running the exact same description line
- across twenty thirty one thousand
whatever number adverts in so then I can
take my ad data and say show me the
information by line by individual lines
and so now I can look and say okay for
my description line - and that's just
for this particular instance the free
shipping option as a standalone
description line - does better than my
my ad that says free shipping option
shop now and so it's it's an easy way to
kind of answer high-level questions
about users or do our testing when you
have so many ads you've got to write
formulas it's not to be powerful it that
way we're still little data does that
help yeah and in the formulas I'm kind
of literally confused on that one
so in the formula stuff you know so I
use formulas or a generic term here
right so like I might make a an excel
sheet where I've got my ad groups listed
out and then my headline is you know
Eagles geography plus company name and
my second headline I just write out
statically and my third headline is
gonna be cheap plus idris name right so
this could be your writing formulas
within Excel to create the ads or you're
just you know using what you've got and
changed your scripts line twos in bulk
for the AdWords editor so it's not an
equal sum plus or this it's just
essentially you're using combination
methods to create your ads does that
help yeah so basically what you're
saying is you're testing the different
lines within the ads and if you have a
huge base of a ads you're using formulas
to help you manage that exactly because
of a guy who no longer
let's they've got a long tail
campaign where I've got you know three
thousand a groups in it but no a group
gets more than a hundred prescience a
month well in like two years I could get
statistical significance for at least
one ad but it's not coming for two years
but I've got you know 300 ad groups and
a hundred impressions each then really
I'm getting thirty thousand impressions
a month so I can now use the aggregate
information at an ad level to have
enough information to know what I've got
successfully confident information to
pick hey this line does better than this
line hmm what do you consider you know
enough data to be significant oh that's
a great question um that depends a lot
on how part the data is so if you know I
mean minimums right often use minimums
like it you know if I'm it depends when
I'm testing for so if I'm testing first
I click the rate then I'm gonna want you
know at least 25 clicks probably more
like a hundred clicks per ad I'm gonna
want well in that case conversions don't
matter on over at least a week of time
but that's gonna give me kind of low
confidence information if I want it if
it's a brand term I'm gonna want you
know 500 clicks on at it and so minimum
viable data depends on how confident you
want to be in your end results but it
also depends on how many deviations it
is away to not get too complex here but
if I've got ten clicks off of 20
impressions now I've got another one
that's one click off of 3,000
depressions my deviation group is so
large that even though it's not a lot of
data it's it's significant in itself if
that makes sense
and there is an Excel plugin which will
do Z squared and chi-squared information
which are standard deviations within
Excel to help calculate some of that and
that plugin is I can't run the name top
of my head I know it exists but I can't
remember its name okay David throw that
in the ask-an-expert form and we'll look
it up and get it back to you
right sounds good I'll set them yeah I'm
good
all right thanks for jumping right you
okay
ed Gary of image factory Fame and master
sir grad a quick question from you for
breath yes
Aloha guys from the Big Island's the
home and Gary yeah well usually I'm in
the answer so I came out here buster
is there a place I can go to get online
training on Excel pivot tables I'm going
to guess I don't know the answer but I'm
going to guess that Khan Academy might
have stuff on there Khan Academy is an
open source open source place to
increase education across the world K
Ahn and they have a lot of videos from
YouTube honestly you could probably
YouTube than pivot tables and see three
thousand ten thousand results okay Khan
Academy has a tendency if they have it
they're usually better because they put
it in a logical ordering step and if you
go to Microsoft's Help Center and look
up office 2010 help they don't do this
for 2013 or the new version 2010 help
does have video examples and and that
would be the place and then finally if
you even want more in and I'll give a
quick shout out to my favorites being a
person if you really want to ask the
really cool someone who knows way more
about this and anyone else
John Gagnon is the he works at Microsoft
he's the Bing ads evangelist and he does
incredible stuff with data and is
constantly writing articles if you ping
him on Twitter he will give you more
resources than you could ever want
awesome does it have you lined up their
gear you have I'll keep you busy for a
while you got it all right and then that
question from are you ready for another
question that let's go okay arts aren't
you had a question for Brett sure yes I
am I did a quick sort using cost and
quality scores and realized that there
was several my high cost towards an
absolute quality score so I went in and
looked at some of the ones that had
sixes and I looked at the expected CTR
words average the add relevant score was
average and the landing page experience
was average so my question is what what
strategy would you recommend to help
boost that up to maybe some sevens I
testing that that's really if your
landing pages AdWords it's all about ad
testing if your so just for everyone
real quick so if you go in and your
relevance and expect a CTR are bold
average then you can test incrementally
different ads you don't have to be
radically different ads if you see that
one of them is below average then you
want to start from scratch right
something completely different to test
now you can still do that anyway but
that's really the differences brand new
or just something a little bit different
testing sure your number one thing to do
there okay okay excellent
appreciated yep also thanks art and
looking just to make sure the rest of
you know waiting for a couple of extra
questions to come in right now that
coast is clear so you may get away with
early exit there bread the the next
workshop is August 14 seven days from
now mobile marketing by Jeff Hasson and
Jeff is teaching how to battle banner
blindness with mobile content
I think this alliteration and the phone
thing is going too far in at the top of
chip I'm supposed to read that out loud
online this is difficult sometimes
all right battling banner blindness with
mobile content I guess it's not that bad
we'll let him off the hook
and David just adds us speaking of being
have you ever had problems with fake
clicks for example analytics shows fewer
sessions that add Center says we're sent
is GA accurate or in its center there is
so watch attempting to line up two data
sources is impossible
Bing knows when someone clicked on the
ad they don't know when your website
load is so GA didn't load the user is
using a privacy blocker privacy badger
than GA won't actually load and collect
the click and so if the percentages are
within ten percent of each other there's
nothing to worry about and and sit on
one of our nationals workshop and talk
data sources and you will quickly see
where this is convenient maddening so if
you're a ten percent not a problem and
then and the only time I ever have
issues with Bing is sometimes their
content network because it's are their
search partner network as a seal open
for ten feet occasionally I'll need to
turn that off but straight big traffic
not a problem is great traffic hope that
answers the question and then I see I'm
trying to pronounce this as a Pollyanna
your open question for bread properly I
just got it close okay appreciate that a
lot
do you mind just touching base again on
on that side you did about variation
match analysis I didn't quite catch how
you separated broad and modified broad
I'm sure so here I've got a I've got a
report right here so let's say I've got
a key well that was way too big all
right come on Excel be nice to me all
right so um a little I've got I've got
six minutes all right so
for everybody real fast this is what's
useful so go to your lines I'm gonna
highlight my [ __ ] three lines I'm gonna
go to view I'm gonna go to freeze panes
and just freeze them here now what that
does is I've got my top row as I scroll
down it keeps my my keys in place so
freeze panes really useful seconds I'm
gonna select the row of data I'm gonna
go to data I'm gonna hit filter this now
allows me to I've got these icons I can
drop and select things by so I'm going
to go to my keyword section I'm going to
create a Texas filter that contains plus
sign so now my keywords here are plus so
I'm going to go to my assuming I had
match type listed I don't at the moment
so let's just pretend this column isn't
campaign is match height so this
happening match site then what I would
do is I would just call this I would
broad and modified and because I'm
filtered I can just drag this double
click drag it down and now all those
only these words would not be considered
modify broad if I had others than they
wouldn't be so I did make this match
types from campaign so if I clear my
filter you would see these didn't get
touched so this would pretend it's exact
match freeze match these wrote the plus
R until left is modified broad that does
that help that old clears it up thank
you perfect also thanks for the question
William and I'm looking to see if we
have anything else in the queue what
we'll do is start the wrap up process
what I'd love you to do you have my
voice on your speakers right now open up
your question-and-answer window let's
know something we did particularly well
or something we could do better than
make it better service if you haven't
signed up for the paid search master
certification course now's the time you
have
I believe included access all the way up
to the starter coaching sessions so it's
a great way to go and yes but there's a
pricing experiment going on
right now if you knew we were doing that
bread but we wanted a sort of lock pose
this morning actually
yeah we're being very open about it
we're actually just trying to open this
up to more people and see if it works
well so check out the website I don't
want to go on too long about that
anything else that you want to add into
the question-and-answer window we'll
leave this open for a little bit and if
we just missed your question and jump in
and put it into the ask an expert forum
inside of mark and motive and that
should do the trick
there's a few extra questions committing
bread do you want to do one more before
we wrap up sure okay one quick question
on this Rita do we have a more elaborate
video on dissecting the account on pivot
tables for Adwords No
so the so what we do have is there's two
videos that are really good on pivot
tables so if I let's just go here if I
could jump to the master course and this
exists in the regular course too and go
into Quality Score
there is an entire video on how to do
what I did in and way more depth on
Quality Score and some examples if we go
to the video archive go to paid search
and archive excel this was oh shoot
Michael what's her name Liana Leone and
I did this together a couple years ago
which is a lot of Adwords analysis you
can do with Excel which covers more than
pivot table she goes in a lot of things
on conditional formatting I touch on
some things on pivot tables and
filtering and so forth those are
probably the two best videos on Excel
that I'm aware of excellent and I hope
that answers your question by the way
very fast navigation set of the market
there I'm impressed
for a while
and then art has a final question this
is last moan take what are some of the
issues maybe some top issues to consider
when you're integrating Google Analytics
data inside Adwords okay creating J data
into AdWords number one okay I'm gonna
take like four minutes here Michael let
me grab one is which data source you use
to track conversions because GA does
last-click conversion and AdWords does
last AdWords click conversion they're
never going to agree so just as a quick
example for everyone here let's say I go
and click on your ad today and I search
for you in four days from now and I
click on your organic listing I convert
AdWords says hey you searched on for
days the cookie window is still open
AdWords puts the conversion at the time
of when I clicked on your ad today
Google Analytics is going to put your ad
on the day of the actual conversion but
put it on to the organic place not the
AdWords place so comparing AdWords and
GA conversion data it will drive you
nuts so which one do you want to use as
your source sometimes you have to use
both sometimes you want to use Adwords
to put the attribution there but you're
doing call tracking and call tracking
has to go into GA then to Adwords the
dad is a little fuzzy then but it's
still better than not tracking calls
that would that would be your absolute
first confer thing um a second is to
ensure the time zone that you're using
for GA and AdWords are the same um
AdWords you can't change the time zone
GA you can if they're in different time
zones then you'll have certain hours of
the day attributed to different days of
the week that's another really big one
three go just go into Adwords and anatta
GA columns um
the overall most reports add the GA
columns was not a problem the the few
that don't like search query we just
walk through
um search query data is nga where you
can see bounce rates by query you can't
see that in AdWords so if your AdWords
you can't see GA on certain types of
reports see if it exists in mga directly
not in the integration as it might um
lastly this if you have multiple who
access your account then make sure
they're listed as GA users because if
they can access your average account and
log in but they're not on the GA account
they will not see the GA segments so
every person who logs in that you want
obviously to see GA data in AdWords you
want to make sure they're listed both in
Adwords and in GA um those are probably
the main considerations for combining GA
networks together alright that's pretty
impressive actually and I hope that
answers your question
our Eric says excellent all right so
again we're gonna go ahead and wrap up
now genders to do a little bit overtime
there and appreciate that you guys knew
which buttons to push I think if we
missed your question by chance I don't
think we did maybe one or two at the end
here and go ahead and put them into the
ask an expert forum we'll try and get
back to those as soon as we can bread
thank you for a very generous session
and I love that you broke into Excel to
show us how it really works this will be
recorded in this part of the archives
for you we're members of market motive
and a lot of things come in and by the
way from folks who are attending I'm
pretty good size class today so Brad
thank you and for the rest of you we'll
see you inside the market lot of courses